so I'm roving i'm the founder and CEO of
price nomics and today i'm just going to
tell you guys a little bit about how we
agree to be two million visitors a month
and how we started to figure out how to
make money from basically just blogging
so what is person onyx and he thought to
almost anyone what we're known for is
being a really big interesting blog um
we're a team of hat writers path
engineers and we have the observation in
the market like newspapers are dying
blogs are like being able to like print
out hundreds of millions of page views a
month but all of them just make money
from eggs so that all this traffic but
they don't really know how to make money
so that's like one half of the world dis
content sites that are all like dying
and then the other half the world are
like Silicon Valley startups and these
people are know how to sell software for
a lot of money but their problem is they
don't really know how to get traffic
like when you start your company that's
going to be the hardest thing how do you
get users how do you distribution how to
get traffic it's all our observation we
made the difference for us as we said
well what have we combine the two what
if we became a really really great
content site to basically use that
content to occasionally promote our own
services and that's what we did a press
nomics our main product is we crawl data
for hedge funds and tech companies and
they pay us between two to ten thousand
dollars a month to get them a feat of
that data every month and the one the
only way we get customers is by writing
about data and attracting people that
way so this talk today is going to be
about basically how do you create great
content
that they can power your whole business
but like you know I think this will be a
pretty honest conversation will try to
be honest and I think a lot of speakers
will be honest with you about like how
you get there and a lot of times when
you read TechCrunch or you read an
Avenger be it sounds like it's a
straight linear path like we came up
with this idea and we were successful it
took us a long time to get there so
let's start about the history of price
and onyx partners our neighbors price
nomics even though it probably doesn't
have to be was I had this idea I sort of
like love getting great deals on things
and I found a bike I really liked on
craigslist i'm on for three hundred
dollars and i turned out I didn't really
like it after like a week so I put it on
craigslist again and I sold her four
thousand dollars a week later and I was
like this is not how a market should
really work you know there should be
like really great price transparency
about how much a bike is like this is
ridiculous so I told some friends we
built together we're like let's just
crawl through craigslist and ebay and
see how much these bikes are selling for
or like iPhones are selling for or
anything are calling for so we built
these crawlers we built this website it
was going to be like kelly blue book for
everything and it was called price
nomics and we go to say and i would sure
like a side project all of us we're
doing other things i started a different
company years before is halfway running
that and i was sounds like a cool idea
how do we apply the Y Combinator and
then you are surprised we've got in next
were like oh crap now it's turns into a
company
yeah well they were like so passionate
about being a price guide but now we're
like stop doing this and so we gotta
know y combinator or like a little you
know the one thing they tell you there
is you have to figure out a way to grow
and early on basically the only way we
were getting users was from google
people would google like how much is my
track five thousand bike worth there
weren't a lot of results for that
because you know like as my example from
arbitrage e-bikes fallacy like there was
no doubt about that so we were showing
up and it was like going pretty well and
well happen we grow faster but we needed
more links you know we need to click
people to cover us we need like
basically do well with Google you need a
lot of content you need people to link
to you so you have a lot of 44 like all
right well let's start a blog and we can
write about our data like the okcupid
blog was really huge then and we're
taught like well let's just do what they
did and you know right about data and
also like talk you through a little bit
about like how we started off and how
we're sort of advantageous some of the
things we did in the beginning the Nash
Valley lattice to go down the path of
mostly blogging and like we did that and
it worked pretty well we started like
going up the ranks and Google and we're
NYC and we remain is managed to raise
like you know over a million dollars in
funding afterwards for great angel
investor isn't like from the outside
world it looked like a sort of perfect
startup you're getting a live the dream
and but internally like every day we
look at the numbers and it was all
driven by Google like other than our
blog and all the users were just coming
in from google and then one day like it
would go down twenty percent and then I
go up ten percent or my
fifty percent or might go up a hundred
percent but it really like are immensely
we figured out that like these are our
users these are Google's users and
that's lately like you know are we going
to be able to build a real business to
stop the back of Google we have to like
think about something else and so while
we were doing this through being a y
combinator being Silicon Valley you just
get to meet a lot of other people that
are doing startups the people would
always come to us and ask like hey we're
trying to crawl these enormous website
that's all you guys do is like crawling
through these sites have so much data
how do you get them can you help us with
this we're all right yeah we'll have
patty with you I'll tell you about this
and that's where someone was like well
you know can we pay you for this data
you're getting and really no we don't
want to make we don't want that friends
day we never hear a price guide and then
eventually we're like well well I guess
when you face two thousand dollars a
month late we just grew out really
absurdly high number husband say like
two hundred dollars a month and they
said yeah oh ok well that's like way
more money and we're making from this
link maintain your site this is one
customer so that's what everything
clicked we're starting to have this
business model in place so we like we'd
write great content that sometimes I'm
all probably data from the web you would
find out about us a very very small
percentage of them would like contact us
and say hey we need the sort of data and
those people we would charge anywhere
between two to ten thousand dollars a
month and then once we like figure it
out that model that it was a little bit
more repeatable and we could write more
awesome stuff we can sell more stuff and
so that's sort of like the story about
how we got here and I'm like there are
so many times in that little story I
told you where we just go totally could
have died yeah
and but the one thing that always like
stuck with people was said they really
liked your blog and that was like the
one thing to be always stove so we got
to write really efficient content we got
to find cool data we got to share it but
I likes to mistake that people love and
that ended up saving us and letting us
like figure out and try new things that
we could like sell to our audience and
that's where we are today so this talk
is sort of aimed at you who's described
charter company and who wants to make
great content so you can get like in the
newspaper or TechCrunch or wherever so
that like people can find out a value so
you can mark your product so you can
test out new things and so you can get
distribution and like everything about
how do you market your startup or how do
you write a blog post that like promotes
yourself just remember this law that no
one cares but don't feel bad about that
like when you can tell someone like
they're busy doing their job they have
like a million other things they don't
care about like what you just email them
to they probably don't have a mental
overhead to even process it and like
don't say you're personally just like no
one cares so you're going to have to
just really really stand out and make
other make people like demand to care
like that you are so special that like
you help them do their job or you're
just so interesting that they care
that's really the only way to get
through in my opinion and so we have one
philosophy about like marketing and PR
anything that is like information
information for us as currency like
we're in the business of like just
giving people information and why do we
do that yeah it helps us like you know
sell things because sometimes we sell
that information to people but mostly
like think of that you want to get
coverage somewhere online and this
person in this reporter at their trailer
job that's a lot of work it takes a lot
of time
research a company to write a blog post
to do anything and how can you convince
that person to spend the time to write
about you like would you like write a
book report about some random person to
talk to you on the street like that
would like to kill your week so like why
don't you do something that can make
their lives just way way easier like
giving a report that like if they write
about it they will look incredible like
one of the first things we wrote about
that like really had a lot of currency
or did really well was then we crawl
through every like iphone and figuring
out how much they were depreciating over
time and we also crawl through every
android phone and how much they were
depreciating over time and we also this
was like two years ago so blackberry
joining hands because the blackberry was
even like a thing now in fairy night
haven't blackberries were depreciating
over time we came out with his index it
was like oh it looks like iPhones
depreciate the less the least really the
best resale value compared to Android's
uh blackberries and we wrote that and
like also like nothing really happened
in the beginning like we just read it we
put in our blog don't like email like
few places we amount like you gotta wait
on TechCrunch me nope entropy and
eventually like one of them saw
automatic cuz like that was a story for
them like iPhones had the lowest
appreciation and like that's not like he
didn't actually put in a ton of work to
like do the calculations himself or
write about it and that made him look
like really smart it helped him do his
job at brought your information in the
world and then that led to like a
torrential like you know everyone that
covered this thing like iPhones are
number one in depreciation or in person
onyx which was just like a couple of
dudes but that was only York Times that
was a high gloss for trails everywhere
and
like just give people information
because like otherwise you're going to
be like you to write about me and
they'll say why you won't have a good
answer other than I would like you to
yeah so how did we get started like and
what do I see fine its information it
could be like awesome data your company
puts together or as by-products of your
company but it can also be like an
anecdote and only you or your company
authentically know and like what what I
mean by that when we when we first
launched it was right before Christmas
and we had arranged for like and cuz
weird y combinator and they like helped
us make sure like TechCrunch would write
about Preston Thomas kelley blue book
for everything and we were like launcher
write a blog post to about like our
company with the launch and and I rip
this thing up that was like because
there's Christmas time or like we're
price guide there's like five use things
you can buy your wife for christmas or
something like something very lame like
but I just Ollie well this is what a
blog is supposed to do like you talk
about your product you like shamelessly
plug it like it's not supposed to be
that popular it's just like a blog and
so but the thing was like Terrence is
going to read bass before Christmas but
they ended a bragger medicine like the
26 so I read this blog post all ready to
go like there's gonna like house
afterwards after we launched about like
you know Christmas presents but was
after Christmas so I couldn't do it I
could write about this thing and so by
accident is like well I got a pretty
something this today and what do I know
about so I felt like well one
interesting thing we did last week was
we emailed all our friends in Y
Combinator and we're like hey and we
were testing at our data and we
by aeron chairs and well like I them on
craigslist and then will resell them to
you at a market and so we even like
selling four hundred dollars and then
source them online using our data for
like 300 350 dollars and afternoon was
like okay why you can write about that
like it's not like that much about our
product really but it's more about how
we did this how would we like go out
there and find these chairs and try to
get people and like try to rip off our
classmates by taking their money um and
that didn't go being like such a better
story like people ask you to like that
so it's authentic this stuff that we
knew even though it was just an anecdote
about us and then like that end up on
hacker news is the number one article
there I was in like all things D it was
sitting like all these places that like
we just written like the boring thing
about our company nothing would have
happened so in the beginning every time
we wrote a blog post it would take us at
least 40 hours and so when you like read
it it might even not even be that many
words and might what kind of breezy the
town like someone just asha like but
that was never the case like it would
take so much time for us to assemble the
data for us to figure out how to
visualize it and for us to tell the
story and we read things like the the
hipster fixie bike index where we
figured out like we're in America a
fixed gear bikes were sign of us and
like doing that because a lot of work I
have to call a lot of data
and and we published had that levaquin
gangbusters we did something about San
Francisco rent prices over a year ago
before like people really were able to
quantify how fast the prices were
increasing in the city I got 30,000
facebook likes but it took this like
almost a month to pull that data
together and visualize it we've done
stuff where we compared Airbnb prices to
hotel prices by crawling through all
these massive websites and like those
ones like that he's a lot of data take a
lot of time but they were the ones that
don't involve a lot of data that we just
write about because we want to bring the
information of the world they we put a
ton a ton a ton of effort into it
sometimes we don't put that much effort
into it though and this was like our
most popular blog post ever it was
called how this is a constable of your
favorite band and we thought it was like
kind of crappy blog post someone had
sent us this data about like how much
does it cost a book like Madonna versus
like Justin Timberlake versus like
everyone and we just like to read our
blog looks like no time and because
we've been doing this so long and people
were sort of expecting interesting
information from us you sort of started
having all these advantages now we put
something up there and I just one blog
post got 1.2 million views and over a
hundred thousand Facebook likes and we
just like threw it on there we thought
like how you're going to send a story
email list it's not good enough they
won't care and so like that didn't
really drive us any I mean we got like a
million visitors in a day did really
like drive any business to us at the
same time you got a lot of business that
day and how that happened we had also
written a piece earlier about
retailmenot and we crawled through all
their Google search results show how
awesome they were an SEO and a 71 from
the time they were the number one result
for coupon related google searches and
then that same day we have that
spike RetailMeNot and the google panda
search update it every time I not got
creamed and their stock price crowd like
thirty percent in a day they're getting
all their traffic from Google and then
all these headstrong analysts started
googling like retailmenot SEO data and
we just showed up and like that day like
almost every big exponent Wall Street
email this it was the same day that like
Madonna was going viral on our site
that's something else that we had
written unrelated was that really taking
off and driving business so as you do
this you'll have your own rules out like
making interesting authentic information
ours like bring information be right
beat interesting like we want to
basically make content it's like the
most interesting articles that are in
the business section in the New York
Times under Wall Street Journal and and
you don't have to like yeah you're not
talking to be invent the wheel every
time like now as we do is we have like
themes like you can tap it's like a
really popular subculture we wrote about
like the business of fish some time like
we you can like just right stuff that
like people feel good when they share it
and some information for us that's like
really surprising or we like saying like
something is and it's like or
the economics of food trucks or
economics of yeah anything you can tell
a story about like how you guys started
I want your friend starting a company
you know the curio cycle is an
entrepreneur and you can just post a
chart that tells an interesting story
and you can come up with various themes
like you keep hitting over and over and
then in the beginning you have to
basically do some work to make its prey
and and after a while like I mean in the
beginning that can write something will
be really cool but nothing will happen
unless you like sort of push it and the
good news is though you'll be pushing a
little bit it can really really spread
because the face
because like one blog reads another blog
whatever you get mentioned like once or
twice are you need to like get on like
some subreddit where you need to get
like somewhere on hacker news and then
eventually a little dis avalanche and
that's like a beauty of beauty like
content today is that you don't have
that many disadvantages versus just
being like the New York Times you know
like they rely on people sharing it on
Facebook just like you rely on people
sharing on Facebook if you make
something as good as watching the new
york times people don't care what's on
your little blog or the new york times
if you're just sharing on twitter and
sharing on Facebook they're just a
blogger needing to some data to write
about and oh right about you just as
quickly as well write about something
that's in the cottage to New York Times
so they put a little effort up front
like you know email journalists and say
hey there's this quick there's a study
be road you might like it you know I do
those things that so really pay off and
eventually like and eventually will like
become easier you know like that article
we wrote we had million visitors that
wouldn't have happened the first day
that we get million visitors going to
read something like you noticed you
would have advantage over time so stick
with it it's not it's not easy and then
finally like we were so like we love our
content so much that were like not all
of us needs to necessarily even promote
our business like ten percent of it
needs to ninety percent of it to cease
to be good and we found it was so good
we like loved it so much so
authentically we even put it in a book
called everything is and we
self-published it and a month ago we
just like put it on our blog we didn't
do anything and that mug that sold
twenty thousand dollars with a lake
profit for us it was the number one econ
book on am
a long span about like for economics and
that was just like the level of
intensity that we put into making our
blog really really really good good like
we're like we think it's so good that
people would buy these recycled blog
posts and we had a new content to it but
it was really just a testament to like
our commitment to making good things and
that they would spread so thank you
that's fresh mountains you guys have a
question please come down you need
opportunity speak to one of the best
content experts I see actually questions
stop yes I'm here
awesome presentation I enjoyed it
definitely to check you guys out after
this so just have a question about how
to get inspiration I guess pour your
content it seems like you take a lot of
time to develop it so what do you do and
then what stands out a cup I guess about
writing it um i guess like we just gets
trapped by things and we find our
interesting we start with that like um
let the other day we were talking about
like the witness protection program over
lunch like what a minute something like
if people actually go in a witness
protection program like when I'm sorry
facebook profiles yeah like everyone
have a lunch conversation and I'm like
well my way just is not that much work
to dig into it and say like now right
now so I was working on a perfect a
piece of that like how the witness
protection program works and I sort of
like a deferral decision like this seems
interesting to us and like sometimes we
like you know will forever be like good
idea we have way up so I 10 bad ideas
and like we really just hope something
someday we find catch crisis is
interesting cool thank you hey how you
doing so on Michael by companies lots of
stops which I call air traffic control
for delivery but I'm curious did my down
i'm looking to increase after that blog
post i would i would guess not I'm just
kidding um nope my question is maybe I
wasn't paying attention in the beginning
is so is your revenue model you being
hired to do data research for other
companies our revenue model is basically
and we will crawl the web like a
customized way for people and so like if
you ever really started from today that
you've always liked a lot of data that
you're like product you're like a
retailer side all
I'm crawling through a marketplace
whatever like it requires at least one
full-time person possibly like a team of
full-time people these central was
changing their painting but you might
get lot oh they're always like very
idiosyncratic things i like getting data
and so what our business model is we
basically will do that for companies we
just specialize in so when you just get
them the feeds of the data and well for
Demi we take like a full-time team at
least one person possibly like one or
two and then person would hate doing it
for us we like love doing it and we like
focus on that so that's that is like you
know eighty percent of around okay so if
you get back logged on request from
other companies will you do that you
outsource it no I mean we're sort of
like building the platform to make it
easier every time like the first time we
did it and it turned us like a couple of
months so I really get the data in the
right way then the next time we get it
just like a month now it takes us like
two weeks to set up a custom or on our
platform and this would also like make
it so that a customer gets rid of run
the data on their on our platform and
monitor like oh this like changed now my
collars not working or this thing
happened but for now it's like every
time we're like building this plane is
flying in terms of like making it easier
for companies get data oh well I enjoyed
your talk thank you again hi honey I
come from the editorial
things so I was wondering if you can
speak a little bit more like dad calling
for dummies sort of the technical side
of things the data that you're finding
like old-fashioned ways all the research
that editors have to do to optimize that
and understand the text i think what
sort of yeah so you're there's always
stuff about data journalism out there
today like you know 538 or box or things
like that and well um you know people
apply to our jobs for right or sometimes
you're like hey I'm for all data like I
did this a project and look like for our
writers we don't have them do any of the
crawling and because of the ones that
that would want to sell look hard to get
we want the real real professionals to
get it and almost nothing we do could be
done by someone that was just like doing
it as a hobby or like I decide thing and
so you know like other people out there
might like have writers or like get the
data to but we like split up so we have
like a professional super professional
vaca crawling we have the writers like
dude a professional writing and so yeah
our philosophy is that it's like too
difficult to do it unless a really
specialize in it and in curling its I
assume there's a technical side of how
the crawling habits and then it's
probably sending the data as well as out
there crawlers do prob let me know what
I mean typically a guy n is synthesizing
it you know like or selling our team
does but stupidly me because I want to
put my stamp of approval like every time
because on the other it has to be right
and and it's not right we lose all our
credibility if we're going to say that
like Airbnb prices or this much we're
just going to tell us it has to really
really be right and it's awesome Utley
like nothing gets out the door without
me you're doing it or approving it so
it's best
something like you it's best to not mess
up so like so I give you a few other
half roll with it like anytime you put
something on the internet like someone
will know it better than you and so you
have to like keep that in mind I like
you have to really really be right
because it'll get out if you make a
mistake or SP definitely like don't give
an opinion on something that you're not
a hundred short Valley have the scope of
the argument very very narrow so you are
the expert in that at least narrow
question so how do you source that
content if you are I mean basically yeah
I mean you have to lecture to work with
so an engineer I think it's like to get
there I my name is one girl shelf so my
question is I felt a question about Y
Combinator so my phone got in and chose
not to join us my first i think is kind
of two part number one you know what the
percentages of people get in choose not
to go and the second is what the
opportunity cost and not joining is um
like I would never not do it like the
people almost like come up to me are
like hey have you raced money and like
how did you do this and I have no idea
how i did it i just animal I see it was
so much easier so it's like the best
thing ever it's are like you got in and
decided not to do it matter now that
would be weird that's what I always tell
him so there may be a future blog post
or something just about the economics of
rejecting like I'm here
it's like me elsewise makes so much
sense i guess i don't know how we were
to raise money like the key thing about
angling when people like Billy about me
all the time like hey can you help me
erase my how did you do it didn't
introduce me to this person and like no
one wants to give money to sound it
wants their money you know like that's a
real problem like you just get a cold
email like hey like i fear the start out
by coal email yeah like can you give me
money they will always say no because it
signals like this person I don't know
signals they want my money which means
there must be something deficient about
them where's like in an incubator at
least like like I'm a trap that way
there that's unfortunate optical and
said it looks like oh love these people
don't really necessarily need my money I
must it must be something great about
that I have to give my money oh yeah I'm
with you i figured that way I can taste
something back and show him something
yeah like a blog post seeing that he's
wrong Oh time for two more questions but
we do within the next two minutes and
I'm Ben Harvey on internet San Francisco
and also started company but he said you
only use blog so I'm kind of wondering
like what your advice or what do you
think about other social media platforms
as opportunity to grow yeah I mean when
I said we all use our blog like
eventually we're most traffic comes in
through his facebook and like a bit of
it comes through Twitter too and like
journalists hang out on Twitter and it's
great like for tracking what's going on
but I mean today like part of the cool
thing is there's no traffic was for
facebook or twitter or other places that
really doesn't matter where you wrote it
you can write it on your
say right on medium to write it on like
in your time to write out a christ-like
jobs time for facebook so like you have
a certain democratize where you can put
content that's my question I just
thought it'd be my holy blow so you have
any tips on like how you structure the
sharing links do you like to put them to
the top of the bottom of the sides there
were to go to service to Adam in custom
right that plug-in so like I think we've
never known a really good answer we put
them at the top and put them at the
bottom and our blog posts are so long
that we can kind of tell some people to
share it right away without possibly
reading three thousand words and then
some of them like they get to the end
and then they will share them but I
think a lot of data to this doesn't us
how our dad I've the surrogate is that
people will just share it on Facebook
like naturally or they'll email and
naturally lady won't even use your
buttons they're just like you're like oh
this thing's so awesome and I go to my
facebook feed and paste the link in and
and so a lot of it is just like people
it's really great people share it no
matter how crappy your buttons are all
right thank you Roman